come to LA let's settle this like men
stop lying and I'm disgusted with you
and you should be disgusted with
yourself too Logan Paul is mad after
being accused of faking a video where he
appears to knock another man out he made
a video saying that the slap was not
real
his boils my blood it all started on
June 9th when Logan posted a video that
appears to show him knocking out a slap
expert who goes by the name slapped for
cash Logan says he invited slap for cash
to his la home to help him train for a
slap contest in Russia that he planned
to enter here's what happened when Logan
gave it a shot don't catch him catch him
catch him the violent maneuver appeared
to knock slap for cash out so hard he
said he didn't even remember it
happening yeah do you remember seeing
the intensity of the situation firsthand
Logan ultimately decided to withdraw
from the slap contest in Russia and
seemingly thought that was the end of it
but that's actually when the drama
started On June 19th an interview with
slap for cash was published on the
YouTube channel Kenny ko where he
alleged the slap was fake he also made
this claim Logan saw the interview and
took to Twitter to share his side of the
story insisting everything was real the
dude is lying through the skin of his
teeth there was no agreement on what to
do or how to react
he had already been paid the slap dock
is not fake you did not have to fall
down to get paid
Logan goes over what he says were the
terms of their arrangements he said he
paid slap for cash $300 plus travel
expenses
to teach him how to slap after Logan
allegedly knocked him out he said he
threw him an extra couple grand because
he felt like he had taken a piece of his
brain congratulations bro you're getting
the notoriety fame clout recognition
that you wanted I'm reacting you got it
bro you win I am disgusted that you
would do this trying to tell a
perpetuate a lie and expose me and my
credibility guys of a videos fake like
I'll tell you a few hours after Logan
posted that video slapped for cash
responded on his Instagram issuing a
challenge hey man you're trying to make
me look bad let's go on the boxing ring
and see what happens you don't want to
go there let's get in the ring to find
out
[Applause]
[Music]